boris johnson stands accused by his own
ethics advisor of putting at risk in his
words uh placing at risk
the standards the high standards that
are necessary uh in around the uh by the
ministerial code that's because lord
guyt who acts as the ethics watchdog for
the prime minister investigates uh
allegations that ministers including the
prime minister have breached the rules
wasn't given access to whatsapp messages
between the prime minister and a wealthy
tory donor uh who was helping set up a
trust which would fund the private
refurbishment of boris johnson's own
flat boris johnson ultimately took 112
000 pounds which he later had to repay
in order to upgrade
the furnishings the fixings uh in the
flat above number 11 inside downing
street boris johnson employed a uh
a well-known designer called lulu little
uh and the cost of that refurbishment
spiraled out of control
boris johnson whatsapped a message to
lord brownlow a tory donor who was
setting up a trust uh for the
refurbishment costs to meet meet the
refurbishment cost saying uh and we have
the exchange for the first time saying
i'm afraid parts of our flat are still a
bit of a tip this is november 2020. i'm
keen to allow lulu little to get on with
it can you possibly ask her to get in
touch for your uh approvals and uh lord
brando goes on to uh to say yes that's
not a problem lord brandler was setting
up a trust that never ended up being
created instead lord browner himself
reached into his own pocket and paid the
money boris johnson has formally been
cleared
of a big breach of the ministerial code
because boris johnson didn't know that
lord brownlow was funding lord
brownlay's trust some might see that as
something of a technicality but uh lord
guide the independent uh ministerial
standards advisor says that is the point
in which boris johnson uh has been
cleared
but i think the ease with which the
prime minister can get access to tens of
thousands of pounds uh for refurbishment
that previous prime ministers would have
had to pay for uh themselves and the
fact that after this started coming out
the prime minister's own office downing
street and the cabinet office didn't go
to the length that might have been
expected in order to procure these
messages that a different watchdog the
electoral commission which is truly
independent got hold of uh do raise
questions about once again raise
questions uh about the state of ethics
at the heart of government uh lord guy
ultimately clearing the prime minister
but some damning language boris johnson
promises to do better lord guide says he
uh hopes that the prime minister will
live up to his promise